catching all 151 monsters in Pokemon go
is a difficult task especially since
certain ones aren't even available yet
or are they I'm Tony and this is your
legendary gamespot news update just this
week a pokemon trainer in ohio managed
to catch one of the legendary birds
Articuno players accused him of cheating
but it turns out the Articuno showing up
was totally legitimate unfortunately
developer niantic has revoked any
legendaries from players who managed to
catch them according to the devs the
pokemons appearance was a mistake and
they wanted to remove them quote as a
measure of fairness this is a bummer
especially since niantic has yet to
announce its plans for officially
releasing any legendary Pokemon this
comes after a series of rather
disappointing updates to Pokemon go
including the removal of tracking
hopefully anyone who called Articuno
will be compensated in some way in the
meantime you can stick with gamespot for
all the latest news from the world of
Pokemon go
you